Marzia quits Youtube
VoiceoverPete Get Bannd from Fiverr
And Wall Street Journal is back at it again!
I'm Poppy Harlow, *Pop*  and this is Peuu Neuus
*shitty news intro*
Good evening! I'm Poppy Harlow, the most respected news women in the industry. *Pop*
*wheeze*
What you all find on this channel is nothing but the fact. And that's fact. That's a fact.
Our first *clap* Story *clap* Comes from Pete, the voiceover man
Sorry. I may have gotten that wrong
VoiceoverPete
Our first story comes
From Voiceover Pete
Voiceover Pete recently got banned from Fiverr
That's right, apparently Fiverr is
on a quest to just destroy their
website completely and decided
to bAn
VoiceoverPete now if you don't know who
Voiceover Pete is he's an epic gamer
A huge memester
And an awesome vOiCe-PeRsOn
guy
We talk about the fAcTs here. Now he was featured
In one of my videos. I mean, it's a
popular meme.
It's practically everywhere at this point
'attention all nine-year-old gamers'
*clap* *clap* *weird finger movements*
Pewdiepie is in great danger.
*Bitch Lasagna instrumental in the background*
He needs your help to wipe out T-series
from YouTube once and for all
we must not let T-series reach 69 MiLliOn subscribers
before he does
Now voiceover Pete has clearly helped PewDiePie
PewDiePie is my employer so
we need to help voiceoverPete back (good english pewds. better than your Swedish at least)
Attention all Tik Tok fans
I understand you have a big question
Why do good girls like bad guys
Alright, I have the aNsWeR
*pewd laughs*
bUt FiRsT
I need the 16 numbers on your credit card
three friggin numbers
*pewd laughs*
Probably VoiceoverPete is most famous for the meme
where he says
"AtTeNTiOn aLL GaMerS"
For us to WiN in this game wether it's
Counter Strike or fORtNite
to reach the EPIC win royale
He needs your credit - mom's credit card number
Thats the j0kE
thREE numbers on the back, the expiration month and date
BUTT 🍑
you GOTTA BE QUICK
so that *inaudible* can SEcURE The fRAG
and ACHIEVE
the EPIC TERRORIST WIN
*Undertale - Megalovania*
*wheeze*
I can't believe
all undertale gamers
Sans is in great danger and he needs your help
to defeat Frisk and save the underground
He's gonna need your credit card *inaudible* *pewd wheezes*
three numbers on the back *pewd continues to laugh*
and the expiration month and year
*pewd laughs*
And once again pew news and meme review
are just *random noises* two worlds colliding
*wheeze*
Now Grandayy posted on twitter saying
aTTention all epic gamers
fiverr just banned
VoiceoverPete